i know all of the juicy potato chips in
the world because they seek them out and
so for me
a snack is heaven
hi i'm padma lakshmi and these are a few
of my favorite snacks mostly indian but
not all
[Music]
so snack culture is huge in india
absolutely huge we love salty crunchy
spicy things we're just eating snacks
constantly we love to munch on stuff
first favorite snack
is this thing it's called hot mix there
are like a million kinds of these in
india this is called namkeen in hindi
it's also called mixture it's a salty
crunchy
savory
sometimes spicy
snacks
[Music]
there's some construction in the
building okay well once i start
crunching this hot mix
you won't be able to hear any of that
so what is this it is a lot of fried
stuff put together there aren't peanuts
in it there are puffed rice grains there
are also fried lentils and then there
are these little vermicelli things you
see them usually you would have it in
the same time as you would have tea you
know with tiffin like at five or if you
were going out for a beer or a cocktail
this would be a great snack i love
actually this one because it's not too
spicy but it's certainly addictive
so next up i have this other indian
snack called muruku
and here are a couple of brands it's
also called chakri this is a south
indian snack muruka is the tamil word
for it it's something that is um made
out of rice flour and cumin and salt and
chili powder
i can't open
so we had a professional package opener
do this for me so this one says it's
spicy and these are baby muricas and
they are super duper crunchy if you have
dental problems watch out be careful
hear how crunchy that is it's the
crunchiest thing you'll ever eat
okay so up next we have masala cashews
so let me break this down this is a
digression but an important one for
all you first you feasters now the word
masala just means spice and it can mean
um a spice blend or
something that has a lot of masala is
also something that's spicy and also it
can be like a seasoning so
here we have
the cashews these have been tossed with
a whole bunch of yummy things
they're usually
have cayenne as well as kashmiri chili
powder which is a milder brighter orange
chili powder i'm sure this has coriander
powder cumin powder and salt
i'm sure it has chaat masala which is
again just another combination of spices
if you're in new york you can get these
masala cashews from collusions
colossians is a store that i grew up in
you haven't been to collusion set aside
two hours of your life and just go there
and browse on a weekday i don't
recommend doing it on saturday you're
gonna get elbowed by a lot of indian
aunties it is so worth it and they have
these masala cashews
[Music]
all right so next up we have masala
munch now the title of this is called
kurkur or kurkure i think it's because
it's an onomatopoeia and this and it's
really interesting because onomatopoeias
i finally opened one
anomalopias are different around the
world
and i think this is called kurkur
because
that's what indian people oh damn that's
what indian people hear when they hear
this i know because i could see my the
aunties in my family going like oh yeah
that's kurkur
kurkur knows i did the head shake i
didn't even mean to
[Music]
when i used to go between india and
america every summer the one thing that
my family in india would ask me to bring
were pringles you can now get pringles
in india they taste pringles taste
different in every country in fact in
india they're slightly thicker and
they're in every airport which is great
when i first came to america when i was
four i just thought pringles were the
best thing in the world not because
there weren't any other crunchy snacks
at my disposal on the country
but because they are so
thin
and perfect and it's like you're
crunching on air
oh
[Music]
okay next up chips and salsa this is one
of my all-time favorite snacks
it's for when i don't have the balls to
make a full plate of nachos but i still
want that crunchy yummy tomatoey feeling
tomatoes are one of my favorite favorite
things to eat whether just with sea salt
and balsamic
or in a salsa or in a million other
things and right now it's tomato season
which is why for my first children's
book i wrote a book called tomatoes for
nila it's based on a story that i used
to tell my daughter krishna it's a story
about a little girl who lives in the
east village with her mom and writes
recipes and it's a multi-generational
story but we started with tomatoes
because tomatoes are ubiquitous in so
many different cultures and they tell us
so much about how food has traveled
tomatoes come from the new world
mesoamerica and then they traveled and
now you can't think of indian food for
example without tomatoes and so many
other cuisines it's a good food vehicle
for teaching kids a lot of things so
please go out and get a copy of tomatoes
for neila
[Music]
and there you have it those are all or
not all who are we kidding those are
some of my favorite snacks indian and
otherwise um
please watch taste the nation we have a
new season coming out it is not season
two it's a mini seasonette so that will
be out on november 4th and if you're
looking for a gift for a young person
please buy my new children's book
tomatoes for nila
[Music]
you